The coronavirus crisis has dragged one issue to the center of the table.
Fake news.
To what extent does freedom of speech protect people who publish news that is
simply lies over the past few months, we've seen all sorts of websites,
even YouTube channels say all sorts of outrageous things about the coronavirus.
And we're not just talking about conspiracy theories either. For example,
many websites have recommended.
Barbarities such as drinking bleach to cure COVID-19. This is false bleach.
Doesn't cure coronavirus, and it's poisonous.
If anyone has considered following any of these tips,
and I can't believe I have to say this, please don't do it. But so much.
Fake news has led many governments to consider creating laws,
to prevent anyone from publishing misleading facts.
And we're not just talking about governments platforms like this one that we're
on now, YouTube or similar ones like Facebook have taken action such.
As this.
That was Facebook dealing with fake news through third-party factor.
Exactly. Everyone is trying to solve the problem of fake news.
Even many YouTubers are actively asking that YouTube itself act forcefully
against some channels that promote hoaxes.
And that's when this story comes up and makes us all rethink everything we
thought about the truth.
Is how wired card went from analysts, darling,
to a $2.2 billion accounting scandal business insider.
No. What you're thinking,
what does a financial scandal have to do with fake news? Well, a lot,
believe me,
we're talking about one of the biggest financial scandals in German history,
a scandal that includes fraud of more than 1.9 billion euros,
not only by German authorities and able to see it.
They also called all those who sounded the first alarm conspirators and
spreaders of fake news.
I know what a lot of you are probably thinking why a card it's the first time
I've ever heard of this company? Well, yes, it's true.
That Wirecard is not the most well-known brand,
but I'm sure you've all used their services.
There's one of the largest payment processing companies in the world.
If you've bought something online, you've unknowingly used Wirecard technology,
especially if you've paid for something related to gambling sites or porn. Yes.
This German startup had specialized in that particular niche market.
And I know what a lot of you are thinking online payments. Well,
I'm sure this company is making a mint right now.
If there's one sector that's benefited from the coronavirus crisis,
it's got to be the online market at a time when we've all bought things online,
online payment companies have increased their business a lot.
So why can't has to be making a lot of money, right? Well,
nothing could be further from the truth.
Check it out.
Wirecard collapses into insolvency, June 25th, 20,
20 financial times.
If, why can't I just become famous for anything in recent months?
It's because it's been part of the biggest financial scandal of the year.
Apparently half of its business has been invented. And here's the juiciest part.
All of this was happening while the German authorities not only turned blind
eye, but they even denounced the journalist who investigated the story.
What were they accusing him of fake news and market manipulation.
You may be surprised, but unlike the traditional press,
the economic press is often much more regulated.
If a financial analyst publishes false information about a company,
it can sink or raise that company's valuation on the stock exchange.
And so there are laws that try to avoid this,
the problem. Well, sometimes these loads can end up chasing the wrong people.
So this video can serve as a cautionary tale about fake news finance and the
price of truth.
Because the questions we're asking today are what exactly is the wire card
scandal? What did the public authorities fail to do?
Why did they not see this coming?
How can things like this be prevented from happening again today,
we go to answer these questions, but first let's look at some history.
It's a great European.
Imagine that you have an e-commerce store and that you sell Hawaiian shirts
online. I buy a shirt from you for 10 euros.
That means that at the end of the transaction, there should be 10 euros,
less in my bank accounts and 10 euros more in yours so far, it all makes sense.
The question is who verifies that both your bank and mine have registered that
St. John's is all your bank is different from mine,
especially if we're in different countries.
So registering such sales is the work of electronic payment company.
And I'm sure.
You already know a lot of companies in this sector, MasterCard visa, well,
Wirecard is a platform that allows your e-commerce sites to accept most,
all the different payment methods in the world.
If I want to pay you with these or MasterCard or any other system,
why I call it makes it possible.
Customers can put various products from different stores into their shopping
basket and pay with their smartphone in one single transaction.
Are you ready for the future of payment?
And this company began in 1919 nine and like so many other internet companies
that were born around that time,
Wirecard nearly disappeared when the.com bubble burst.
If the coronavirus crisis has been the boom time for internet companies,
the 2000 crisis, it was quite the opposite.
And it was at a time when Wirecard was worth less than a roll of toilet paper.
That's the antihero of our story appeared Mr. Marcus Braun
From looking at the bad guy in Robocop,
Marcus Braun had a really great idea to make this company really take off porn
and gambling. You may be surprised,
but these companies are usually completely isolated from the rest of the
e-commerce market. For example,
most payment method companies refuse to work with porn companies. However,
those pages also need payment processing to lots of payments.
So why a card became the only payment company that didn't discriminate against
adult entertainment conclusion,
Ron bought a dilapidated business and five years later was entering the German
stock exchange. That's right. And what did they want to do this for? Well,
they needed quick funding to be able to take the next step international
expansion.
And.
Now I want you to keep this fact mind at that time, the Wirecard share price.
Was it five euros? Remember this number because it's important,
five euros per share. We have all that liquidity provided by multiple investors.
Why can't make the bigly in 2007,
they opened an office in Singapore and hired the second antihero in this story.
[inaudible] director of Wirecard in Asia, and
Exactly another gentleman who also looks like the bad guy in a B-movie.
And what was this man's strategy for conquering Asia? Well,
very easy by everything that moved suddenly,
Wirecard went out to buy all kinds of small businesses that offered online
payments in local markets, a small company in the Philippines,
another company in Dubai and so on.
So that by 2014 Wirecard already offered services in Australia, New Zealand,
South Africa, and Turkey. By now the share price had already climbed to 30.
That's yeah.
In less than 10 years,
it had multiplied its value by six shareholder meetings looked like birthday
parties every year was better than the last, but make no mistake.
Even at that time,
there were signs that things were too good to be true by then,
the financial times had already begun to be suspicious.
[Inaudible].
Wirecard is a little known German tech stock worth 5 billion Euro and the
puzzle. It grows at breakneck pace, but bias,
obscure payment companies around the world,
which keep the growth going financial times.
This article is from 2050 and it basically posts one big question.
How is it possible that they bought ruined or failing companies in Asia and that
in just one year, make them so profitable?
No one was able to explain it for sure.
And this should have prompted the financial authorities to start analyzing this
company in Germany.
The authority that handles these things is called the Baffin. However,
they didn't seem to be up to the job of getting inside the company to carry out
inspections, why it was a great German miracle,
something like a European Facebook that any country would dream of having to
give you an idea. In 2016,
they bought the online payments division of city group. In other words,
they entered the U S market through the front door.
They did something similar in Brazil by then the share price was already more
than 46 euros. And at that time, 2017, a German magazine published this.
50 Million Euro puzzle of the Wirecard stock market,
miracle manager, magazine dot D E basically.
Why? I can't say that they bought payment companies in Asia that were virtually
unknown and worth every little. They took their client portfolio,
restructured the company and inside a year,
they were making profits to put it another way. In just five years,
Wirecard was already tripling its profits more over in January, 2019.
Why a card was worth more than Deutsche bank itself? That is it.
Stock market value was higher than Germany's largest bank.
This is when they entered the Dax 30,
which is the index with the largest companies on the German stock exchange.
[Inaudible] suddenly.
They were everyone's darling.
They went from being a payments method company that worked with porn pages to
the platform used by more than 100 airlines and supermarket chains like Aldi.
But then the stock price was way up at 190.
[Inaudible].
Of course, this is nothing compared to Amazon or Facebook,
but it's still a good result. In 15 years,
the stock had gone from five-year-olds for the 190 rows. It's not bad at all.
Is it? Well, all of a sudden, just when everyone was gushing over Wirecard,
the stock price started to fall for the first time.
And you'll probably wondering why.
Look at this,
the stock market Maverick.
What if I told you that you could make money when a stock price falls,
that is technically you can buy shares of companies that you think are going to
get worse. This technique is called short selling. I'll tell you how it works.
Imagine that you have Wirecard shares in December, 2018,
its market price at that time is 190 euros at that moment. I say, Hey,
let me your action.
And I'll give it back to you in a year with interest you say, okay, great.
I didn't plan on selling it. So knock yourself out.
When you.
I me, the action. I said it, and I put that $190 per share in my pocket.
I hope that in a year's time,
why I can't shares are going to crash in the stock market.
If my calculations are correct in December, 2019, the Wirecard stock will be,
let's say 10 euros. And at that point I buy the stock again for 10 euros,
I return it with interest and what I just made 180 euros per share from a
company that's doing badly. As you can imagine, this is a very risky practice.
And usually people who buy short are usually a very particular type of.
Investor.
A short sellers. I mean,
they're basically people who are going against the market.
Think about it in January, 2019,
why our client was going from strength to strength.
The German Baffin claimed that the company had all its accounts in order Ernest
and young,
which is the company that audited its accounts confirmed that why cards business
had no problems. In other words, all sources of authority said,
why a card is the future.
You'd have to be crazy to buy short with a company like that. Right? Well,
that's kind of the way that short sellers are a kind of unique tribe within the
world of finance. Something like conspiracy theorists,
but with one difference in this case, your truth comes at a price.
You're putting your money on the line because you really think something's not
going as well as everyone else believes.
Short investors usually have very bad reputation at the end of the day.
They benefit when everything goes wrong for almost everyone else.
And all of that explains why then February, 2019, we found a story.
Like this boss in bans,
short sales of Wirecard shares after market cap.
Exactly the German financial authorities wanting to protect their little
Facebook.
They didn't want a bunch of short term investors sinking the company at the end
of the day. If other investors see how many people there are buying short,
the stock price is likely to drop and no one wanted them.
Fall down.
At the time.
Those lone wolves betting against Wirecard was seen as the classic conspirators
in tinfoil hats. And of course,
many thought that the financial times was publishing a series of fake news
articles. And as we said at the beginning,
fake news in the world of finance is punishable.
Often the German financial watchdog has filed a criminal complaint against two
financial times journalists and several short sellers accusing them of potential
market manipulation over reports about suspected accounting irregularities at
Wirecard.
I know what you're all thinking.
That's a bit much the German state was fighting the only ones who were telling
the truth. And yes, it's true. Now that we know how the story ends.
It's easy to say it was an injustice,
but what would you have thought if you had read this news in 2019,
what would you have afford?
If you had been told that a newspaper is publishing fake news and that they're
being taken to court,
would you have said it was an injustice or maybe you would have been happy that
something was finally being done about fake news leaks?
I'll leave it to you to think about in any case,
not even baffles efforts served to prevent Wirecard from failing there's enough.
The scandal that rocks Germany.
October, 2019, why a card stock price is now at 110 euros.
As much as Baffin has banned short term purchases.
The financial times continues to publish analysis.
That leaves the company looking far from being in a good position.
They still don't understand how it's possible to buy small businesses in Asia
and achieve so much profit in such a short amount of time. And around that time,
when the market was starting to turn its back on Wirecard,
the company came together and made this decision.
Wirecard hires KPMG for independent audit after financial times allegation.
In case that headline didn't sink in. Let me explain.
Large companies are required to let another outside company review their
accounts.
Periodically these companies that review the accounts of other companies are
called auditors' in today's global economy.
There are four major audit companies,
which are often called the big four Deloitte PricewaterhouseCoopers.
Ewind formerly known as Ernst and young and K P M G until this point,
Eli had audited Wirecard accounts,
but since the market continued not to trust Wirecard, they said, okay,
we're going to be audited externally. So you can feel calmer.
And probably the fact that KPMG was hired was also by design,
after rule Marcus Braun,
CEO of the company that looks like the bad guy from Robocop had previously
worked at KPMG.
He probably thought his KPMG friends would be more sympathetic to him than any
other auditors. However, this move could not have gone any worse.
Take a look at this.
Wirecard bombs again, following a devastating KPMG special audit report.
Basically both Eli and KPMG discovered that Wirecard had invented
1.9 billion euros in profits. Exactly. According to Leichhardt,
you were unstoppable in the Philippines. According to them,
almost all Philippine residents use their systems so successful.
Have they been in this country that they had revenues of 1.9 billion euros so
far everyone had believed these figures at the end of the day. Why would,
why they can't lie?
Who's going to go all the way to the Philippines to check if the business or
not. Well, at this point,
someone did decide to approach Wirecard alleged offices in Manila with such
turnover. You would imagine a huge glimmering building, right? Well,
none of that, the Philippines Wirecard empire was housed in a humble office,
shared with a bus company, but it doesn't end there.
The Philippines central bank claimed that it barely knew why
With such a huge business,
why call it should have been investigated by the central bank.
What's more under Philippine law.
If a company's volume exceeds 5% of the foreign currency reserves hold by an
entire country,
they're required to want to go and inspection 2 billion would have been more
than enough to warrant a routine inspection by the authorities. However,
why our current Philippines was a house of cards. As you can imagine,
as soon as this news was discovered why cards managers began to drop like flies.
[Inaudible] police raid Wirecard entities in Singapore after reports of fraud,
allegations of payments, giant
wildcards, former CEO, Marcus Bron arrested after $2 billion scandal explodes.
Why call? It has already filed for bankruptcy.
And some of its managers have gone missing the company's attorney denies.
Having had any contact with his client.
The chief accountant is missing in the Philippines and the whole world is
starting to distrust Germany.
If the financial authorities in that country failed to see this scandal,
how many other companies could be up to something similar for the time being the
names of Baffin officials who are directly involved in this scandal are only
beginning to emerge. Think about it in this case,
it is simply not that the authorities were not able to detect fraud.
It is that they actively worked to silence all those who ran.
[Inaudible].
So now the question is over to you. How could this scandal have been avoided?
Who controls the regulators?
To what extent can this story prompt us to see the fake news debate in a
different light, leave your answers in the comments.
So I really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast,
a provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. And it also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.